[Music]
have you guys heard of Bon Appetit yes
the moccasins the magazine but also but
the drama okay like drama
well it's relevant to what's going on in
society right now Oh drama
yeah right here here okay so Bon Appetit
is the food magazine they also do like
videos and like their Test Kitchen and
stuff and so the editor in chief named
oh my gosh where the hell is his name
Adam Rapoport he has like a photo of his
past has recently surfaced um first
black face this is what he looks like
and one Halloween him in his wife your
rights to copy to brown face
oh they decided to dress up as Puerto
Ricans and so this this photo surfaced
recently especially with this climate
right now there's a lot of people in
powerful positions that are apologizing
for their racist past and so this dude
he ended up getting called out and
eventually did he did they put makeup on
or anything
mmm I guess he's that white that that's
his Brown I just see like a Dodgers fan
well it was because of the caption to
where it's like oh yeah me and my puppy
hashtag fodi quo so like they're clearly
what are they what's their background
um like horror games like trying to be a
puerto rican for halloween so it's just
like dressing up as a culture you know
it's brown facing so they're calling
this brown face is it what's his
background his background oh he's the
editor in chief sorry is nick background
oh I don't know he's white I'm assuming
he's Mexican his last name is Rappaport
oh yeah that's not a porter Rican I
guess I have to learn more of it I guess
I have to learn more about it to be more
offended about it cuz I'm like I'm not
there yet are they wearing the clothes I
think we're both on the same but they
were wearing makeup yeah cuz I thought
he was being plain daddy hanky or
something can we have a
and an offended scientist be here to be
like okay here's what's offensive about
it has to be I think it's just okay I
think it's cuz it's a hashtag yeah it's
like I'll be the change so this is how
he views oh well this is his lens of
Puerto Ricans when they're like wait
we're not a [ __ ] costume okay got it
where he was wearing makeup that's why I
thought I was missing the part that he
like darkened himself I thought he even
gave myself a little sunburn or
something I don't know I don't know no
no I think he's just trying to okay so
her hair do you like a pretty cool girl
like the stereotype of got it I get it
now so like wearing gold chains saying
I'm black and doing this yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay this is what I've been saying
sorry nobody knows what I've been saying
in the freaking entertainment industry
because I don't look Filipina or I don't
look Asian even though I'm half asian
and half white but I look latina and so
they would always make me do latina
things like they would be like can you
do an accent can you can you act more
latina and I was I felt like that was so
like racist were you like just they
wanted me to be more of a stereotype
yeah especially in comedy like in the
comedy the CBS diversity showcase they
they needed me to be a stereotype of a
Latina woman and it was just so
insulting you're like I'm not I'm Asian
though yeah what I'm Asian to it even if
I was latina
I'd be so offended yeah yeah they make
you do like oh yeah yeah like although
that like we don't even do [ __ ] like
that no I know it's stupid really do
that to black actors also like ghetto be
more hood what is ghetto like you know
ratchet yeah what is that I don't know
that's y'all stuff yeah
hello I'm just your director right Oh
gets aware of like this like British
actor was a keen Peele
oh yeah I can't be oh yeah yeah he was
able are like male being like American
black more than the actual American yeah
look its job anyway back to this story
here so Adam he eventually after all
head of
backlash he ended up posting this it
says down as editor-in-chief of Bon
Apetit to reflect on the work that I
need to do as a human being and to allow
Bon Appetit to get to a better place so
here is my what if it was a long time
ago and he doesn't do that stuff it was
2013 the original 13 thing is I think
with this it's when people found out
about it like since this has never
happened nobody knew about it
it's a very it's a gotcha you thing like
if you would have got ahead of this like
look you know yeah well I'll talk about
this let me just let y'all know what I
did or deleted the phone there's some
[ __ ] that you sometimes forget cuz like
it didn't come from a place of anything
you know yeah no I think that's what I
always Kareem abdul-jabbar said this
about like counseling people he said
what did they do the thing was that
considered offensive then did they know
that was considered offensive then I
like that do they apologize now and have
they changed like that's a better
spectrum with which to judge you know
like so Bernie Mac has this this set
that I love um from Kings of Comedy but
he uses the f-word like a lot right so
the time that came out that wasn't
really that offensive yeah yeah right
but now it got it went viral again like
Donald six months ago
and I was like oh my gosh this is like
several right but but the thing is like
so using Kareem abdul-jabbar's thing
like that was offensive then but not as
offensive at it as it is now so you know
if Bernie Mac were alive he would
probably have to you know he would be
able to make that type of joke you know
he would have to apologize for for for
how that comes across right so it's like
a lot of times people don't know like
I'll use the term we were talking about
this at all different time the term
[ __ ] right it's offensive but I didn't
I didn't know like I interviewed a trans
person on one of my shows asked and she
was saying how how its offensive right
but people thought it was descriptive
you know I thought it was a descriptive
I didn't know was offensive but I only
learned that like he's in January of
last year you don't I mean so if I use
that term seven years ago I might not
have thought it was offensive then and I
think you should allow people to learn
from
but if you learn from something and you
know and then you still use it then
obviously you don't you're not trying to
become a better person right so I think
that's the that's the issue that we have
to hold people to is where are their
intentions at what was the climate of
life well here's the thing more about
this specific story though so oh oh
there's more is more boylee an assistant
food editor at bon appetit she she looks
like Steve is sick I know so she ended
up posting on her Instagram stories this
and so would you I'm angry and disgusted
by the photo of Rapoport in brown face
I've asked for his resignation this is
just a symptom of the system systemic
racism that runs rampant within the
whole conde nast as a whole I've been at
Bon Appetit for 10 months I'm 35 years
old and have over 15 years of
professional experience I was hired as
an assistant editor at 50k to assist
mostly white editors was significantly
less experienced than me I've been
pushed in front of the video as the
display of diversity in reality
currently oh no currently only white
editors are paid for their video
appearance none of the people of color
have been compensated bro you running
that you run into shady operations just
the beginning and there's more more
Mickey there's more bone Appetit well
just to focus on her is um so like she
was saying that during the application
process she asked for 65k a year and
then an HR at the company so that they
only had 50k for the position so she
took it even though she has a [ __ ] ton
more experience than other like people
that are white that are obviously
getting paid a lot more and also this is
in New York City like do you survive
over 450 cake it's insane
yeah so anyway so then um like she said
is that they asked her to stand in the
background photo shoots and video shoots
and then also those this other instance
where she had an assignment to go to
Philadelphia for a feature with three
black chefs but because of the
fact that this publication quote doesn't
have a great history of working with
black chefs the chef's that she was
supposed to work with they had asked
that all the staff be black and when she
got there she didn't know that that's
what they requested and obviously she is
in black and so that just created a
really really awkward situation and it
was very strange for everyone involved
and so um and and it was also like this
other chef who came out and was like
[ __ ] that I will never work with Bon
Apetit again that they had her do a
couple videos and she only got pay like
400 400 a video a video yeah and then so
they it's just very problematic to the
point where now other chefs that are in
these videos they have voiced their
support for Sola and for bye-bye-bye
puck people so black and indigenous bi
POC yeah I don't know is that yeah yeah
i POC the whole thing okay so yeah so
they said that they will not continue to
be in front of the camera until bi POC
people are given fair titles fair
salaries fair compensation for their
work so also what the cuisines there was
another thing that they wouldn't yeah
they wouldn't do any African cuisines
cuz they're like well we don't think our
readers or viewers and we think that's
too complicated for them we don't they
probably don't have those in green
they're dis and their readers to it it's
not my team Bon Appetit material that's
smart but they would do these like long
ass Asian meals like that took like 60
hours to do and had like all these crazy
ingredients today but they would
highlight those chefs in that like
African rise it's too much
you gotta boil it you got pockets my are
scratch but is it all cooking hot like
complicated yeah
for me it is if you try to go to like
traditional recipes at all there's
always something in any culture that
takes like over a day to make
I'm killing live food on my table it's
like moving around I can't get to it I
think it's all pretty I mean that's
probably the hardest thing to do yeah
but would that cover it all
yeah beside no when I was looking at
this drama because everyone was talking
about it on my Twitter timeline but they
would say ba instead of Bon Apetit
pulling it out they were like and ba did
this and ba did that and I looked up ba
cuz I didn't know who they were talking
about and it's Boeing it's like that's
the Boeing stock abbreviation people it
was like by puck what does it stand for
black so it's like it's it's um its
distinguishing the fact that black
Americans and indigenous Native
Americans they they go through a
different like a completely different
experience than other like people of
color so it's like an intentional
classification yeah like distinction so
who are not be bi POC maybe like like
regular pxk god that's not that is white
got it oh they're just regular PLC's
yeah yeah I need to push you aside as I
did bet you you're just like regular
basic p.m. cui PLC okay probably yeah
I think I don't know so black in in
Native Americans basically in Alaska
Native got it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]